Louis mentionnait dans ses fuites de
documents du Pentagone dont certains
brosses un portrait détaillé de la
guerre en Ukraine les forces respectives
des deux camps leur vulnérabilité
militaire les pertes aussi qu'ils ont
subi depuis le début d'un invasion russe
il y a 14 mois alors quels sont les
implications pour les troubles de Kiev
j'en parle avec Justin Massy les
professeurs de sciences politiques à
l'Université du Québec à Montréal
bonsoir Monsieur Massy bonsoir alors il
s'agit de la plus grande fuite
d'informations secrètes américaine
depuis le début de cette invasion est-ce
que vous pouvez nous donner quelques
exemples concrets d'après ce qu'on
rapporte bien sûr
oui voilà ça nous permet de mieux
comprendre un peu cette guerre qui est
parfois un peu opaque où on navigue dans
la parfois la désinformation c'est pas
trop distinguer le vrai du faux alors il
y a quelques informations qui sont très
intéressantes notamment sur l'état de
préparation des forces ukrainiennes qui
ont été prépare leur fameuses
contrefensive dans les prochaines
semaines et on sait que ce qu'on apprend
dans les documents c'est vrai c'est qu'à
la fin avril 9 des brigades qui sont
formés par les troupes de l'OTAN serait
prête qui aurait présentement des forces
spéciales notamment des États-Unis du
Royaume-Uni de la France présentement
sur le territoire ukrainien que
l'Ukraine manquerait de munitions
notamment pour sa défense antérienne
vous savez pour se prémunir contre ces
attaques de missile russe contre ces
infrastructures et ses résidences là
c'est les endroits où les gens habitent
aussi que les États-Unis même
connaissent très très bien le moment et
les cibles des frappes russes les
connaissent à l'avance ils sont capables
des divulguer cette information là au
ukrainien et d'autres détails comme ça
sur l'état de préparation et sur la
guerre
et peut-être certains alliés aussi comme
la Corée du Sud l'Egypte qui pèse qui
considère donner un soutien soit la
Russie soit l'Ukraine pour les aider
dans cette dans leur dans l'évasion en
cours évidemment il y a certains des
gouvernements qui ont démenti ces
informations et on sait toujours pas
dans quelle mesure elles sont véridiques
ou pas ces informations
voilà parce que justement plusieurs pays
ont dénoncé on dit que c'était pas vrai
les Ukrainiens disent que c'est faux les
Français disent qu'ils n'ont pas de
forces spéciales la Corée du Sud dit
qu'elle ne considère pas envoyer des
munitions à l'ukrain ce qui violeraient
sa constitution ou c'est sa politique
étrangère mais d'un autre côté les
officiels américains disent que c'est un
cauchemar une ni pas l'information ça
semble très véridique dans la mesure où
ça semble être des photos prises de
documents secrets top secret des
États-Unis donc ont vu les réactions
très importantes disons dans la
communauté internationale on peut penser
que quand même un fond de vérité dans
ces informations qui ont été révélées on
sent beaucoup d'inquiétudes là du côté
des États-Unis et donc si elles sont
vraies si quels sont les implications
pour cette contre-offensive ukrainienne
donc qui est très attendue dont on parle
de depuis plusieurs mois déjà
une des choses que les documents
révèlent c'est que faudrait s'attendre à
des gains très modestes de la
contrepensive ukrainienne parce que lors
des problèmes de munitions notamment
c'est en dessin donc beaucoup de soutien
à faire par le système depuis décembre
dernier en vue de cette rencontre
français mais ce serait en dessin de ce
qui est qui sont les besoins on le
voyait avec le premier sucrinique et on
en a besoin davantage pour être capable
d'atteindre nos objectifs mais aussi on
révèle que l'état de formation et
d'équipements des troupes du grainet
n'est peut-être pas à la hauteur non
plus avec les fortifications russes
aussi dans la ligne défensive dans le
sud des listes l'eau viseront à aller
supprimer à reprendre du territoire et
très très dense et donc ce sera beaucoup
plus difficile dans les prochaines
semaines pour les Ukrainiens de faire
des gains c'est ce qu'on devrait pas
s'attendre par exemple à des libérations
d'aussi grand territoire par exemple
comme on a connu à l'automne dernier
dans la région de quartier notamment
donc ça a des implications ça peut avoir
des implications très sérieuses parce
que la Russie serait donc au courant de
l'état des forces ukrainiennes au fond
voilà ça peut donner de l'information au
rassemblement russe qui ne savait
peut-être pas on sait pas exactement ce
qu'il savait de l'état de préparation
des forces ukrainiennes d'un autre côté
ce que ça démonte c'est que les
renseignement et les
présidents russes le Kremlin et tout
l'appareil militaire russe sont
hautement pénétrées par le renseignement
américain qui connaissent beaucoup de
détails sur les stratégies russes
notamment et donc possiblement que ça va
amener les Russes à essayer de resserrer
trouver à qui qui est victime de cette
de cette pénétration de leur parler
service de renseignement de la CIA
notamment ou la NSA américaines donc ça
peut jouer des deux côtés c'est pas
clair exactement dans quelle mesure les
rues sont appris des choses à travers
ces vues là mais clairement les rues
s'en les Américains parlant savent
beaucoup sur la stratégie américaine et
russe présentant qui est en cours dans
leur évasion et ça pourrait peut-être
aussi amener les alliés qui on espère
offrir plus de soutien aux Ukrainiens vu
justement ce qu'on apprend dans ces dans
ces fuites là c'est à dire qu'il
manquerait peut-être de munitions qui
manquerait de capacités pour mener à
bien les libération de la plus grande
partie du territoire qui l'espère dans
les prochaines semaines donc au fond ça
pourrait profiter des deux côtés c'est
ce que vous dites
c'est possible personnellement j'espère
que ça pourra amener les Occidentaux
donner plus de plus d'armes plus de
missions lourdes on l'a vu présentement
avec l'annonce canadienne de donner des
armes légères mais ce qui est nécessaire
pour cette contrefensive là c'est
notamment des munitions pour de
l'artillerie pour les défenses aériennes
notamment donc des munitions très
lourdes qui sont difficiles de
production au Canada en a très peu qui
sont difficiles d'accès sur la scène
internationale aussi d'où la question
et ce qu'on apprend dans les documents
c'est que les souvenirs après son soit
la Corée du Sud pour qu'elle en livre
plus de 300000 notamment alors que la
Corée du Sud est plutôt tiraillée
présentement et ça aide d'ailleurs son
gouvernement dans l'embarras donc
peut-être que ça peut forcer une plus
grande pression sur les Occidentaux
peut-être que ça peut aussi révéler au
Russe peut-être des fuites ou des
éléments de vulnérabilité de leur de
leur de leur secret si vous voulez
militaire donc décisionnel parce que
clairement les États-Unis en savent
beaucoup sur le Kremlin et leur
stratégie en cours
on n'a pas fini d'en apprendre sur ce
conflit avec ses fuites merci beaucoup
juste à Massy je vous en prie au revoir